- Let's go out and
something trending on the
interim Sure To give you all the fields,
this is what I'm liking.
93 year old, Mrs. B there's
one song that stands
out as the greatest above all
the rest.
No, it's not one of mine.
I know. I was shocked too.
It's known for its cool
rhythm and catchy lyrics.
It's just the kind of tune
that brings people together.
I'm talking about the hokey pokey people.
So for her birthday this year,
the neighborhood got together
to put their right foot in and
put their left foot and
they surprised Mrs. B
with a hokey pokey flash
mob, which is awesome.
It's a rad birthday gift.
Your neighbors are awesome.
We have Mrs B on the line,
along with her neighbor, Melanie
who organized this surprise.
They watch on KNBC in Kansas city.
It's great to meet you.
Oh, I love the sunflowers.
First of all, I'm going
to comment on those.
Those are awesome.
Happy birthday, Mrs. B.
- (Mrs. B) Thank you
- Absolutely.
So Mrs B, what makes the hokey pokey
such a great song for you?
- It's just a happy,
silly
song.
I knew the melody
and nurse would be good at leading the
whole block.
So I've got the CD with
Brad, Anthony,
and that's what they're dancing to.
- I love it.
I love that they all
got together and did it.
That's so amazing. So, Melanie,
how did you come up with this surprise
and convince everybody
to do the hokey pokey
on someone's front lawn?
- (Melanie,) Well, to be honest, Mrs. B
told me about how much she loves music.
And we talk about that all the time,
about how much she loves music.
And she just said that she thought
that my daughter and I would be good at
leading the hokey pokey and you know.
And we were she says,
She says, it just,
it took a little time to organize it
for awhile, you know, summer passed by
and it just didn't happen.
And then we learned it was
going to be her 93rd birthday.
And so we made invitations
and we put them out on everyone's door.
And lo and behold on her birthday
from up the street and down the street
came neighbors.
Some that we knew
some that we didn't know, a puppy came.
Right.
And we,
you know, put all of
our whole selves in and.
- I love it.
I love what a cool thing
like your whole neighborhood came
together and did that's so cool.
Thank you so much, Melanie.
And thank you Mrs. B.
I'm liking your posts right now
and that's,
that's not all y'all
are season long partner
pilot pen The go-to pin
of the Kelly Clarkson show wants to honor
ultimate overachievers just like you
and just cool people like you.
So they're going to be using their G2
jelling pen to write
you a check for a thousand dollars.
So that's 500 for each of you.
Yes!
Thank you so much guys for joining us.